- On this episode, we talk
about closing the sale,
your drive getting in
the way of relationships,
and something insane happens
in the middle of the street.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Gary Vee.
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
- [Gary] This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Want to take a step back?
This I don't have to move
but you can get more of it.
What's that?
Move over?
[DRock] And...
- What number is this?
- [India] 142.
- 142?
- [DRock] And action.
- Hi, everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 142
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Little gloomy here in
this city, but my heart
is not gloomy, as I've just
landed from Indianapolis
on a tremendous weekend,
went to an amazing wedding.
Flew into Indie, on connecting
flights, grinded, got there,
and then the payoff came through
as the New York Jets stunned
the Indianapolis Colts.
You know Andrew Luck was 14 and one
coming off of losses.
Pretty excited, I'm in a good mood,
that 10 and six prediction
that you all made fun of
is starting to look a little bit better.
I think this team is
better than people think.
I'm excited.
I know a ton of you are Eagle fans.
Looking forward to smashing
your faces in this weekend.
Thought the official prediction
comes later in the week,
and we'll see what that's all about, so.
Live in New York,
and some other exciting news.
India is finally back after being away
for six and a half months.
- That was a long trip.
- Yeah, it was a long time.
- It was a really long trip.
- It was.
- Got a pretty rad t-shirt on.
Are these now available for sale?
I know we paid like 4,000
dollars to have this come.
Is it up?
Like now?
It's up, alright, so
Staphon
(bell rings)
link it up,
link it in Facebook and YouTube
and also play this little
clip that happened yesterday
after the Jets game.
(snaps fingers)
- Shut up.
- [Voiceover] Let's go.
One more time.
- [Everyone in unison]
J-E-T-S, Jets, Jets, Jets.
- Alright, India.
- [India] Yeah.
- You're a little rusty doing this.
- I am, too.
- Let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Jordan asks,
"I've been hustling since the age of 14."
"I now work 12, maybe 15 hours a day."
"I love what I do, but
sometimes I fear my drive"
"works against me,
particularly when it comes to"
"getting in the way of
relationships with friends."
"How do you deal with that?"
"I can't switch off."
- Yeah, I mean, this is something
I struggle with as well,
I mean when you're on 24/7-365,
it's difficult to shut
down, it's difficult to
change from in the zone to
in the zone, I don't, and it
works in reverse, too,
and I'm sure, right, like
right now it's hard for
me to re-trigger back into
the work zone off the high
of the sports brain
that I was rolling with
over the weekend.
Look, I think that
actions speak louder than words.
And if these relationships matter to you,
you're gonna figure out how to hack
and figure it out.
It's as simple as that, there's
just nothing else to say.
Hello.
And so, you know,
you've got to put in the work.
You've got to learn how
to shut down, I mean
sometimes it takes
an hour, two hours,
three hours, four hours.
Maybe some sort of routine, you know
working out has been a good transition
period for me, you know.
That's worked for me in the past,
or in the recent times.
Something that lets you transition.
Or what I tend to do...
Hey, little man...
- Oh, sorry.
- No, no worries.
I think that another thing that I did
that was kind of strategic was
I rated and ranked my relationships
and then when I was segueing
into off of work mode
into a weekend or the holidays,
I would
actually schedule meetings according to
what I thought of them,
so like, my mom would be later than maybe
a solid friend.
Because then I'd feel
like I was in the rhythm
of that zone, so.
I think you've gotta hack
and make it work for you,
but your actions are louder
than your words, meaning
you can't have the excuse
of, "My brain is always on."
It means that you've chosen your business,
your entrepreneurship and your ambition
over those relationships.
Which, by the way, and this is not
super popular,
I find that to be okay.
I don't think it's noble.
I don't think it's nice.
It's just a reality.
And there's a lot of people that do it.
You know, especially as you look
higher and higher up the pyramid.
You look at the Oprahs
and the Michael Jordans.
You know.
These are the choices
that people make, and so
I think you've gotta make yours,
and I think that you
need to live your life
and not take the judgment
of all these people.
However,
you know, just accomplishing your goals,
the monies, the sports teams,
whatever they are,
to have that by yourself,
and not to share that
with the people you love the most,
I think is a fairly lonely
place, and you need to
keep that into serious consideration.
- [Voiceover] Sahil asks,
"Why did you stop forcing people to ask
"questions from Instagram?"
- This is a great
question, Sahil, I actually
picked this out and sent it to the team.
Because, I felt that I
finally had picked up
my rhythm and momentum on Instagram.
If you look back at the
point when I was really
pushing that narrative as
a function of this show,
I was hovering in the 30, 40,
50 thousand follower range.
Not that following matters,
but don't forget, on Instagram
it matters a little bit more,
because I feel the attention
grab was there and
everybody's seeing everything,
so I'd rather have a
hundred thousand there,
than maybe a million person e-mail list or
a million Twitter followers.
So I was believing in Instagram.
I knew I needed to build it up,
and really, I created
a function on this show
to create more awareness,
more behavior,
more interaction between me and you,
and Instagram, and you and your friends
on Instagram finding out
about me on Instagram.
So it was very tactical, very strategic.
I stopped asking because I feel as though
I've gotten to a better place
where I've got better cadence
and momentum, there's ads now.
I don't want to create unlimited friction
with you and myself so, like,
I want you to be able to ask questions
the way you want to ask them.
So, it was a strategy in a moment of time
for three to four months.
I executed what I needed out of it,
and I move on the the next
strategy, and the reason I
picked this question, is I
want to make it very ever green
to everybody and make them understand that
strategies have life cycles.
What worked for you three, four years ago,
or three, four months ago,
or three, four days ago,
can be debated and switched.
And I think way too many people
find something that works
for them, and they milk it
until there's nothing left
in the cow.
- [Voiceover] Charles asks,
"What service do you use to
make these amazing images?"
- Charles, that's a
very, very good question.
This one's super easy.
This speaks to something
I believe, which is
scaling the unscalable.
Every time people ask
me about image quotes.
This one (camera clicks),
and this one (camera clicks).
You got some work today, Staphon.
And this one (camera clicks).
People always tweet, and they're like,
"What app do you use, what do you do?"
Nope.
Just use the great Andrew
and Zak design team.
Mainly Andrew now, who also
designed this amazing t-shirt.
Buy it, now (bell rings).
And so, you know, really
what I'm doing there
is just scaling the unscaleable.
You know, there is no app.
Everybody thinks everything's
got to be so scalable.
No, this is done by hand.
I have a design person, obviously look.
And it's interesting.
I have debated turning it into an app
and opening it up to everybody.
But for now it's just done by hand.
There's a lot of texting.
I'll actually pull out my phone, yeah.
There's a lot of texting that
goes on between me and Andrew.
Where I just get a thought
and, you know, just.
Get ready, DRock.
Are you gonna wanna have my?
Are you gonna wanna have my phone?
No, I'm not gonna give it to you, so...
Because you're not gonna
be there, so you can't do
it like you like to normally edit.
But let's just find Andrew.
And...
Okay.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- See it?
- So there you go.
You could've been a bus.
With an image of me from
the Monday morning video
in the background.
And a smaller font saying
"Watch the video now."
I mean, you now, and
then it happens.
Good, old-fashioned
thoughts and execution.
Keep it simple.
Let's go.
Where was I going with that?
I feel like I was about to
go into some sort of like...
- [Voicoever] Igor asks,
"When is it okay to lie in business?"
- That's interesting.
The 14-year-old version
of me would have said,
"Anytime, all the time, go for it."
You know, I think the answer is never.
I don't see any value prop.
I think that having self-confidence and
believing that you can do
something you've never done before
is a great thing for business.
But I think you gotta lay
those cards out to the
person that's making that decision.
You can't say, "We've executed
a campaign like this before,"
Sorry.
You can't say, "I've done this before."
"I've sold this before."
What you could say is, "I
truly believe I can do it
"because of these things."
But faking the funk
has diminishing returns,
puts you in a precarious spot,
and when you define it as "lying" versus
"a slight little embellishment"
or a little bit of hyperbole
when you go to lying, I
think that has no place
in the business world, or in life.
And take it from somebody
who grew up a liar.
It was very tough for me as
a kid to break that habit.
This is one of the
disproportionate reasons
I value my dad's fatherly advice.
He really snapped me out of it.
It's taken me a long time.
I truly believe it's the reason
that most people struggle
with consuming me at first,
and don't know how to take me,
because I do think there's
a lot of bullshit DNA
that I started with,
but I chipped away, chipped away.
And that's the scoop.
No, no place.
- Can you watch the video?
- Video?
- (unclear) sent it to us.
Do you have headphones?
- Yeah, I've got headphones.
We're really hacking this show together.
- Yeah.
- Sup, man.
- Gary...Vaynerchuk?
- Yeah.
What's your name?
- Adam Keebler.
- Adam, that was pretty amazing,
thank you for doing
that, that was stunning.
- Do your thing.
- Thanks, brother.
Holy shit, that was awesome.
- [Voiceover] Very weird.
- That was unbelievable.
That's one of the great humblebrag,
lucky moments of all time, alright.
That was insane.
Alright, here we go.
- Hey, Gary, what's going
on, Sean Mitchell here.
I've got a sales question for you.
In the last couple of weeks,
I've lost two really big deals
that I was anticipating closing.
On the first call, I felt
like I did a really solid job,
at uncovering their
challenges, in matching up
our products, solutions
to those challenges,
but on the second call, they
ended up not moving forward
and it was a huge surprise to me, so--
- Huge surprise--
- What is your advice to try
and minimize the surprise
- [Voicoever] Baba, ba--
- No.
Thanks so much.
- Great question.
Don't steal my headphones, India.
Come off of six month vacation,
stealing my headphones.
First of all, and I think AJ
is better at this than me,
I always think we're gonna
win the sale, because
I'm so good at being a salesman.
But one of the great
ways to not be surprised
on losing a sale is to
never think you've got it.
I think that's actually
a stunningly interesting
aspect of it.
So I think, not buying
into your own bullshit
or hype is important.
I also am a big fan of back-channeling.
I do think that you
could've been e-mailing
and contacting the clients.
Some clients are turned off by that.
Others can really give
you some information,
depends on your relationship
with that client.
But really the truth is
it's very tough to mitigate this.
I mean, that's the game, right?
That's the high of sales.
You go in for the kill,
and you don't know
necessarily if you've made it
happen or not, and so
I think teetering expectations,
trying to communicate
back-channel during the time.
Sometimes the squeakiest
wheel gets the oil.
Sometimes the squeakiest wheel gets
taken off and replaced by a wheel.
It's just a way you've got to
figure out your own cadence.
Your own touch.
I'm a big fan of,
I always say I like things sold
before I start selling them.
So, if you're going in for pitches
a lot of times, I like
having relationships,
putting out content,
before those things.
I think that's
really an important variable in sales,
which is fundamentally selling
before you're actually
going in for the sale.
I do believe an answer
on the #AskGaryVee Show
will lead to a business
opportunity in the future.
That's selling before selling.
And so that's it, I mean you can
do what you can do before the fact,
but once you're in the game
you can back-channel a little bit,
you can teeter your expectations,
but you've got to let the results
play out the way they will.
That's a good show.
I think people really like
when I'm in New York City
I think I gotta start
grabbing people, too.
Just randomly.
I interacted, I don't know if
you noticed a little bit more.
Including what I know
so many of you thought
was as planted person.
I just hope they believe.
That was unbelievable.
Statement of the day.
Just tell me about what
you think about this show.
Tell me about what you
think about this setting.
I'm thinking about getting
outside a little bit more.
Especially with the winter.
You know, I get a--
What was that face?
You can talk.
- [DRock] Starting to get cold.
And the cameras...
- You're soft DRock.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)